a majority of the 2020 Democrats were in
San Francisco this past weekend and they
were seeking to win over the very
progressive delegates of the California
Democratic Party convention but at what
cost here with analysis media guru
pollster Frank Luntz all right Frank I
want to start with this 14 of the
candidates were there but notably absent
was the front-runner Joe Biden and his
competitors use the occasion to take oil
not so thinly veiled shots at him
throughout some say if we all just calm
down
the Republicans will come to their
senses but our country is in a time of
crisis the time for small ideas is over
the riskiest thing we could do is try
too hard to play it safe we don't need a
crime bill we need a hope bill there is
a debate among presidential candidates
who have spoken to you here in this room
and those who have chosen for whatever
reason not to be in this room Frank do
you think Biden skip this because it
allows them to kind of try to outdo each
other on the left front and so Biden can
just look reasonable if I comparison
well if I was advising him I would have
told him to skip this because the
senator the vice president does not want
to be compared to his opponents until he
gets on the debate stage and that it's
only about 23 24 days from now so
because the vice president has such a
lead his goal is you don't want to be
side by side with them you don't want to
be compared to them you only want to do
it when it really matters so I actually
think it was a good strategy to skip
California now Frank I want to give you
a sense of what this crowd was like in
San Francisco here's what happened when
candidates John Delaney and John
Hickenlooper
tried to offer a little dose of reality
if we want to beat Donald Trump and
achieve big progressive goals socialism
is not the answer I was reelected
[Applause]
medicare-for-all may sound good but it's
actually not good policy nor is it good
politics I'm telling you
I'm telling you
that's Frank it sounds like I was
speaking at the Democratic convention in
California those guys have no chance in
this party they should both become
Republicans well the the problem now for
the Democrats is that the core their
base vote is so far on the left with
these policies but I want to remind
viewers this is a great exercise for
them because what they don't realize is
how much the Democrats have changed how
much the policies have moved to the left
and on every single issue the activists
can't wait to boo the moderates in the
party this is just like the Republicans
from 2016 it's just the mirror image on
the left and of course no confab and San
Fran would be complete without San Fran
grand man popping in that's Nancy Pelosi
listen to the crowd when she talks Trump
special counsel Mulder warned us in the
starkest terms that there was an attack
on our own election what is the
president covering
this isn't about politics it's about
patriotism we will go where the facts
lead us we will insist on the truth we
will build on an ironclad case to act
well they're screaming and peach and
peach and Peach Frank well look this is
now the center of the Democratic Party
has moved to the left of Nancy Pelosi
and it's going to be a challenge for
them to move back after the election but
this makes perfect sense this is the
primary voter this is the caucus voter
so I'm not surprised that there's that
emotional and that passionate
yeah and they had to push through the
needles and the human waste on the
streets to get to the convention no
doubt Frank great analysis as always